[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Ramon hello everyone
oh well I guess uh I guess it's time to
zone welcome back cinnamons for night
two of our game of zones watch party for
those who don't know and weren't here
last night I'm Adam and I'm Craig and
and people want to know who the melena
brothers are we're the guys who made
game of zones at least initially started
as us and then we grew out into a big
team at bleach airport when they wanted
to make more episodes and what we're
going to be watching tonight is season
four which is our first season with a
team and when we actually could make
more episodes so Craig do you have
anything you want to say about will be
doing tonight yeah yeah after we show
season four we're gonna show you a few
deleted scenes they're not animated
they're just storyboards and they're
really crappy storyboards but the audio
is on a quality level that you'll
understand but we'll get ya later
so stick around yeah so
and what we're gonna do just - you guys
know is that we're gonna play the
episodes we'll stop in between the
episodes answer some questions and while
the episodes are playing we'll talk a
little bit about some of the fun facts
in that episode so yeah if you watch so
if you want to watch the episode in full
we're gonna be talking over it
so this is not gonna be the ideal place
to fully watch the episode in silence
alright let's let's uh get into the zone
right so here we go eating's odyssey
which was about Kevin Durant's free
agency that's where this season starts
and then a lot of interesting stuff that
became canon
this is when our animation or even
actually got professional and like on a
next level and you'll see that because
we had our first horse ever in game of
zone - brother we're really excited
about this moment these horses are a big
part of Game of Thrones and so the first
thing we did season four well I must be
doing a horse in it time for me to test
the markets in case you're wondering I
do Stephen a Dempsey so Stephen a Tim
say it's a bit of a deep sink if you
haven't Navy it's a Kiwi exit and the
Kiwi accents a bit different than the
Austrian accent be so if you do either
well Kevin I do what I want - the
Wizards fan yesterday that's nice to
hear the wizards you'll have this
services you'll see actually behind
Kevin Durant weight is a very tiny
Easter Egg when it's a sign things
players are not allowed to have in the
locker room and it includes mace
crossbows hammers magic stats all these
weapon that because of Gilbert Arenas
when he brought the gun into the locker
room we have MS list of medieval weapons
they can't bring to a locker room
they're also I don't even know if Craig
and I do John Wall and Bradley Beal and
I don't even know which one I don't even
know I look like body on the line for
this that's actually actually was
perfectly timed you told us about in
these got Brooks you're Scott Brooks
know that Craig along Scott Brooks in
the ena is what so here here we see
manner Ginobili has Tony Parker's number
and this drives me crazy we screwed up
and this lives forever now so yeah we
try to find every wrong number in there
and we missed this one and it eats away
at us
also my ran for this scene is Seoul box
which is a deviation from Game of
Thrones that really bothered me because
that's not how the White Walkers were
created but we just needed to do it
because we had explained it back we just
didn't know how to end that scene so
when in doubt just go with the reference
so and what yeah
yourself everyone loves a kowai laughs
by the way I love the Big Cheese thick
painting behind to join us it's fine
Bret Brown there your old teammates just
the speaking of the class and I feel
like a homo will cook this do this
respect a note of your burning Jersey
people will call you a coward there's a
banner in the background there it says
the is a very very good regular season
that was the year they got 73 wins if
you know this oh yeah that was here
before right yeah yeah smoking whatever
the equivalent it's a medieval vape of a
name of zoned wherever they smoke their
people there's a Kevin Love with this
incredibly scary face that we just never
yeah Kevin Love looks ill very ill there
and that's a but that means Sean uni I
shout out the chod because I told Sean I
gave him the note make them look sick
and like medieval make me look like they
have the plague or something like that
and so he followed the notes could see
but now like yeah Kevin Love low very
Hill what other thing is we gave Jerry
Smith all of his actual tattoos and it
was a complete disaster for animation
quick pause it for a sec yeah so oh go
ahead yeah so we gave Jerry Smith all
like all those tattoos and then we
realized after we designed it that the
animators were like we cannot move these
tattoos around because it's complete
nightmare
so you'll see he just stands like froze
in the back with his arm up and whenever
Jam Smith has tattoos very minimal
movement so a lot of a lot of people are
wondering the the big elephant in the
room is why are we ending the show so
we'll just give that other way because I
think that's going to come up each night
so first of all the bleach report is not
canceling gamers owns this is something
that game bleach report takes a lot of
pride in they love it it's one you know
and and so it's not something they would
cancel it's more that we felt like we
had written all the medieval basketball
jokes I possibly possibly can and we
just need a little break and want to try
something different
creatively because what last thing we
want to do and also like this is a cool
opportunity to like end it after Game of
Thrones was done and to do it in a way
where it doesn't go on too long we're
worried about like this joke just
becoming too old and like and
overstaying our welcome and so I think
there's there's something elegant in
just something knowing when to end and
this just felt like the time to end that
doesn't mean we won't bring gamer zones
back in the future but but we just felt
it was time to try something else for
now yeah I mean we have some interests
outside of sports and you know could be
interesting to explore those interests
will say but I'm going to now introduce
episode 2 which is the changing of the
guard in which we see a Jimmy Butler and
Dwyane Wade riding on their horses to
Chicago very different we call very
different Jimmy Butler here but I must
then obviously later and we had to do a
dramatic pivot and Jimmy Butler's
character after the Timberwolves
practice incident Alma's used to play -
yeah so that's Mario Jesus a versus Kyle
Lowry no is that going wait booze no oh
that's so weird we we don't a super team
together
beautiful we kind of felt that like the
natural reaction to like Wayne weight on
the Bulls look like oh my god doing
weights on the Bulls I forgot like we
kept thinking that were like I kept
forgetting there's on the Bulls that
season and so we kind of gave yeah and
we also gave Mary Chalmers a really
dirty force we must be going on because
oh yeah when you're not great at
basketball your horse saw yes he's great
at basketball don't be wrong but like
when you're definitely better than me
good German your horse like his eyes
don't play yeah great horse though we
can't brought that horse back oh you
know we're horse things but oh wait go
back a second this is an easter egg yeah
no one caught if you normally the the
fans catch everything we had Fred
Hoiberg hiding in the tree spying on
Jimmy for the guard backs you could see
his head so in the corner there yeah you
can see it on the writer screen under
the be our logo and he was built we had
this whole scene for the GAR the GAR
packs that we were gonna do and and it
involved like the GAR packs was this
creature that was living down in the
cellars and that Derrick Rose was pushed
out of the tower as bran and that's how
he heard his knees because he discovered
that the GARP axe had this whole plan to
keep Jimmy Butler from being as good as
Michael Jordan and the whole thing was
that Michael Jordan was went to the
Wizards to learn magic there like dark
magic and they use that using that dark
magic to create the GAR paths so that he
would always be the goat in Chicago in
Chicago would never be it would never be
anyone better than him so great yes
problem was that would have been like an
hour-long episode and so I just decided
to go with this it alright anyway we
could keep going oh yeah also we'll
answer questions and the next ethnics
pretty
[Music]
the sad part yeah so had to Cleveland so
this isn't really loved yeah he loves
like the feeling of like 90s nostalgia
like happy movies and the quirky
professor trope and so we went with that
for Mike D'Antoni that means a sporty
professor that runs the rockets and
doesn't spare meant a lot let's say
hello and welcome you do use done oh why
thank you
and you must be the no scouting
apprentice also this is the introduction
I am your spell shooting guard there
James Harden like all the rails are
using all the Easter eggs that we do
yeah like this is like this is the first
thing we packed in with Easter eggs
which is like oh and by the way that's
actually the point yeah everything that
we like yeah that's ton of you've like
that's a six second clock there seven
seven o'clock for seven seconds to let
you kind of view and the hunt of Easter
eggs on the thing all the books are
filled with this whole shelf is inbound
place yes because this is like one of
the 20 I so plays and that's why for no
good reason really sorry if you go to
the comments somewhere on YouTube
someone listed like every book title so
if you want to read them all that might
be an easier way to find it thank you
whoever did that the people in the
contact you are defense like you know
and other team has the ball and there's
a purple retirement book their school
which is a awesome none of that here
it's a waste of energy and it's no fun
of rice and Glenn for the gray fence
here example the Mobley dish
beautiful partnership between a heart
and and D'Antoni
and hearted would go on to score a lot
of points all right let's hold here for
a second and let's answer a question
here so let's see
oops I'm in the wrong channel here I
gotta go to my questions channel here
and let's see ooh gee man says Craig
looks like Thomas
I actually got me for Halloween not
following for my birthday a Silicon
Valley like Pied Piper Pied Piper
sweater and then I was Thomas
Middleditch as Richard Hendricks for
Halloween so yeah it's an algorithm
might I want to invent a new eager
Internet
that's my and amazing amazing impression
so someone asked about how do we feel
about season eight of Game of Thrones
and I'll start Craig which is so this is
obviously our namesake here and this
game of Thrones is like one of the best
shows I've ever seen it's incredible
however season 8 if I'm being completely
honest was a little disappointing to me
I can't I can't criticize it because if
birth this are like our whole show here
but season 8 and actually from season 5
on it started to go downhill but season
8 was uh was little was a little rough
yeah for me I will say though I
sympathize with the writers because I
think they're put into a really tough
situation but that being said you know
yeah the only it's it's one of the
greatest shows of all time but like it's
it's interesting to observe what
happened in that last season and to
understand what happened and then like
learn from that and hopefully we can be
hopefully we can not mimic that I don't
season so all right let's uh let's pick
back up here on three unless you're
something to say Craig
now let's go okay so I don't know if you
guys remember Charles Oakley incident at
MSG but this was right after a long ago
I know there's been other incidents
since that incident quite the opposite
actually
the whole city cheers on outside these
um you'll see by the way Dolan sucks at
losing on the on the wall there yeah
foreshadowing has a ban it's not right
you're a legend trip-hop is later we see
him playing also you'll notice all the
triangles on the wall that was because
of the triangle asana players especially
where was the run is how these days well
I'm here to return the favor
no come on we don't have much time what
do you mean what are you doing we're
getting you out of here Darington the
key
toss it no no Joe Keenan Derek so so
good to go family issues what what you
think here yeah well then toss it
[Music]
the classic metaphors yeah the old I
can't shoot the guy can't shoot joke but
I will say that like we make a lot of
the jokes about guys who can't shoot but
like it's all about the timing in my
opinion that scene is all about the
timing of the joke but you know what's
gonna happen but the about it's the work
they're feeling a good 20 seconds okay
on the scene do you want oh we can only
draw like to draw enough player heads
that's why everyone is in helmets icing
and underneath that helmet is Mario
Chalmers Brown that keeps showing what
actually happens
Oh Rick singers have settled for the
eighth we are not in eighth year of my
gal offense now as I said we will not be
a sincere updating it which I see for
better then all record what actually
happened we stopped they're gonna be
sexy
yes so we were like okay great
also fun Easter Egg is I think the
Pistons you see their mortgage blog the
house was a depressant yeah that's the
first time I've missed ins so let's take
a couple questions yes that yeah I just
wanna the first time we see the pistons
and the next time we see the Pistons is
the Isle of Van Gundy but that was like
their only appearance for a very long
time and we had a lot of comments for
Pistons fan saying we gotta put the
Pistons in so
LG s 0 for 2 says Adam and Craig what
are your favorite characters in GOC
favorite characters to voice and he says
my favorite is LeBron because of the
draft lottery episode and the deleted
scene so Craig what are your favorite
characters in GOC and favorite
characters to voice I mean Mary Chalmers
is probably one of my favorite
characters the voice well bias there
yeah I know but it's just so easy to do
him like he do you cannot like Michael
Jordan I don't know it's just like I
feel like it's my natural British form
if I were a British person I'd be like
that annoying friend that talks too much
or something so it's just like like you
know I think yeah like one of my
favorite is like any like like kristaps
porzingis even though he doesn't talk
like this but like I like to do like
Eastern European accent because a lot of
what they say is very funny because like
if this sounds like funny like perfect
strangers or something or like yes so I
like that and I also like a little super
cool can we go sort this
they phoned the day also I even though
it hurts my voice I like to do Dame
Lillard I like to do Thoris of me for
some air I would have brother whom vana
yeah I don't think so
with Oros of mare and of course is
always fun what's his name flighty rock
is a good accent you do oh yeah
foxes are smart foxes are smart that's a
good one
and who else who else alright we'll do
one more question and then let's see
someone says why is Obama in game of
zones great question so the reason that
Obama is in a game of zone is because we
were asked by daryl morey the GM of the
Houston Rockets - who also runs the
Sloan Sports conference to do a special
game of zones to kick off that
conference and the keynote speaker of
the conference that year was Barack
Obama and so we included him in there
with Sam hinkie and and that's why Obama
is in there and speaking of Sam hinkie
the next episode is a special one guys
this is for us as Sixers fans I I was
stressing a little much about writing
this like it had to be perfect wait yeah
Craig I know we're not there yet
oh wait we're not there yet okay no but
it was originally episode 4 it was
originally going to be episode you know
when I was crazy
memory is tradewinds and that one is
actually interesting because we did we
wanted to do something about the trade
deadline and the big trade that year was
the boogie cousins trade he went from
the Kings the pelicans and we decided to
not do it episode about that and instead
cover like the minor trades that way
less people were talking about and I'm
kind of proud of Boyan and circus yeah
yeah Boyan and then serge ibaka
but the rapper's magic episode is like
one of my favorite episodes
all time so I yeah I really and we
apparently a month I thought a couple
Monty Python scenes here we really love
the feeling of : response that they have
up from up in the tower and so we
thought it'd be a fun way to do a trade
so we'll start it off in let's play the
episode yeah so you'll notice here
Jeremy Lin's voice is exactly the same
as Melos voice and that's because I did
both those voices exactly the same so
they don't have range this could be our
ticket out of here
also me in line for the first pick some
of these guys definitely a really keen
Lopez they're looking also very ill oh
boy yeah we found out that Billy King
was a fan right was episode aired and
then we had that line about Billy King
in us not a deal
Oh young you're going to washing fellow
your car was improvised by Adam they
expect you in the booth right right oh
yeah I'm very sad this is sauce yes
celebration all the tears I love all you
guys
we also snuck in F bomb in there but we
covered it up by Brooklyn fest talking
over Jeremy Lin has been on a lot of
teams any other trace through pull or no
Kenny Atkinson by the way in real life
great guy
he popped into the office moves you
learn out
[Music]
so this is all the magic
he's got the rabbit in there miss Frank
Vogel and I am young bum also you
flowers
I love characters to tried hit mark Adam
can we try drink rolling we are it's a
fun thing to do
you could have Terrence Ross well what
does he do he's like an older Norman no
no Terry do like you know I like Helen
Terrence Ross has an arrow and his
shields like right before this they were
like wow you know more though some
people might call me and consisted so
maybe I'm not with good 3d player by the
way I I remember I just went on Reddit
and I searched his name I was just like
seeing what people said about him and
that's how I got my information because
I just I don't know anything about
actual I mean I know basketball but like
I don't know it enough that yeah
basically make the character speak like
someone else in speaking
him not how he oh this horse well what
are you do
he scores three points again and what
does the horse do it's a it's a horse he
walks around with people on it I don't
know
that's horse things well it's all things
that's a the chin there's a horse's ass
horsing you never actually called the
was yeah well here but he on the wall
which you you wanted to add in that
creep aazephyr you wanted to add it the
the thing about America's only being a
fifth pick in the draft because you
thought it was a little too mean to
marry his own yeah that we just trained
him for a horse so you wanted to say
something complimentary about him but
Mary Facebook yeah and Ryan laughing
emoji it was a good word about it so now
we like marry her Sonya the someone it's
a couple questions did not like him
just kidding so let's see so someone
asked about that seeing how did y'all
come up with the Demaret trade Co that's
that's first season six will cover the
later I thought of it that was that was
this one but that's not how long were
the sessions when writing each episode
so that's that's a good question
so I'll just say this which is this
first season we didn't have a writer it
was just the two of us and one of the
hard parts of the process is that we
don't know we don't have a process for
writing like there's no we just like or
like okay you got to do another episode
shoot and then we go on Reddit and then
we go on we watch NBA games listen to
podcast and and then we talk about stuff
sometimes we watch Game of Thrones
scenes and we just hope that something
falls out we shake the tree and hope
that an idea falls out there's and so
the problem there is that we can go
weeks without having an idea and we have
a really high bar for what we want to do
an episode about so I don't know if you
about how long you think the writing
process takes Craig and one other thing
I'll say actually is that for us the
writing process goes throughout the
entire cartoon like we come up with the
idea and then we do a bunch of drafts on
it and then
as we're recording we write new parts
for it like we think of new ways to
improv stuff and then we were really
writing the episode throughout the whole
thing I want to answer a question from
Damon Conway how does an actual
basketball game work in this universe
great question and we've put sorry ass
question thank you
so we yeah we haven't shown a full
basketball game and you know we've
always been a little cautious showing it
because it's a lot to animate but
basically it's like a much rougher
version of modern basketball where fouls
the fouls that are allowed are a lot
more violent so you can use weapons but
you know you also are trying to score on
the hoop but like you might get blocked
by like a warhammer or some like that
and the depending on where you're
playing in different regions the rules
are slightly different so you could play
in a certain land where they have the
hoops really far apart you have to use
catapults to launch them into the basket
and you can play in another place where
there's multiple hoops and things like
that it's like it's very crude early
stages of basketball they're still
figuring things out it's a little more
lawless I don't know if you may need to
add Adam if I yeah real quickly I'll
just say like the idea is this is that
everyone everyone talks about the 90s
it's like oh my god it was so rough in
the 90s so we extrapolate that all the
way back to like medieval times when it
was like oh it was like no fouls and
everyone was armored up and they're
using weapons and it was just everyone
bashed each other's brains and played
like super violent basketball that's
kind of what it is although when you see
basketball in certain shots they don't
really use the weapons like in Episode
eight of this season that we're gonna
show you now like is when we see really
basketball played for the first time
actually obviously the process episode
has a block but mainly the heart in
westbrook episode so anyway without
further ado let's jump into episode 5
actually there's a little bit you got to
kind of get a sense of basketball here's
our first time yeah the violence fun
fact about that will get their little
cuties the brow and a famine - in the
background the guy shooting basketballs
die Brown never actually shoot their
animation we have the resources to at
the time we're in a huge rush mr. Marcus
if you get a technical you'll be
suspended again I'm sorry alright this
has been I mean he always does what do
you think literally that's rule right
and then get dejected
yeah but they just they just wrote some
real bad here it's not good what's
interesting here is that he was what's
his name Marcus all was the hound in an
earlier episode we did and here is when
DeMarcus Cousins kind of starts becoming
the hound
not really tough guy yet eventually yeah
so this is where we chapter referee in
half Tony brothers apparently apparently
there was a little someone at the leaks
all bet with her not to go real so we
were talking a little mindful that yeah
but here my new home here's where we
make Harrison Barnes who Margaery Tyrell
launch of will just not probably
humanely yes we'd match them up with but
we had been waiting a long time to make
Mark Cuban Olenna of house Mavericks
kids me so yeah let's let let's let this
sit for a second and then I'll give you
an interesting backstory here for this
yeah
please sit would you like a rib
no thank you Oh hungry talked over this
later
the hair joke that's one of my topics I
okay so the reason for the reason for
the scene is that Mark Cuban got
offended because bleacher report social
had posted a something that says like
jerk forever and it was like Dirk
shooting an airborne was an obvious joke
it was a light-hearted joke Mark Cuban
went and not publicly about it and so we
asked the president before the time then
it said for you in Finland do a little
thing and get him back from Zoe this was
sort of like our way to make fun of him
for being so sensitive about people
making fun of now making light of the
Maverick see on this this is because he
went after Voight reporters you know guy
just a no expert cool guy noted well if
I'm being honest I there were a lot of
sensors and not enough minutes frankly I
was very sick of losing a child there's
no need to worry anymore
here in Dallas never take that chin up I
think I was I'm art hubei with Jack oh
yes yeah yes that's mood he's the
greatest yeah Greg I don't even know
what choices we do I'm nervous
[Music]
right this is wherever so we mashed up
you think he's Olenna Tyrell Mark Cuban
but he's actually Olenna Tyrell Plus
Ramsey Baldy
so this is a little confusing and a lot
of people didn't realize what we're
going for here what we're implying is
that we posit for that we're applying
that the Mavericks mascot champ made
light of Dirk at some point in the past
and as a result marked cut out his ribs
and fed its owner owes no well that's
all and then showed it to him like you
know the sausage in Game of Thrones and
if you don't know what I'm referencing
you should watch Game of Thrones and
you'll realize pretty quickly
all right so a couple of questions sorry
which is first Rocco Guevara says what
did mark think of this episode and
actually mark was cool about it he
actually retweeted it and said what he's
a cool guy
yeah so Mark Cuban was cool about it and
then I then that was the end of that
beef and someone else says the animation
is incredible in this series so that's
Andre Rosie thank you shout out to all
our amazing animators under Chris
Bollinger and I could list off all the
animators but they're all incredible you
should check them out and they're all in
the in the credits and one more here
let's see have you guys met Mark Cuban
because of this scene no no we have not
I wonder if you'd even remember this
scene we know though we know from the
later scene that Dirk and I think Mark
had a good lab because a podcast with
Ernie or whatever they did the stream
with Ernie dapper had seen his episode
that we did later with that marks in so
and he was cool about it so now the next
episode is the big process episode and
when we're done with this episode we'll
tell you a story about the time we met
Sam hinkie
at the Sloan conference and it was
incredibly awkward but this is this is a
big episode for us to see where we're
from South Jersey right outside
Philadelphia so we've been Sixers fans
our whole lives so is have so meant a
lot to us because we're process guys so
let's let's crawl the tape
[Music]
there's a wah-wah
Gotti's the way to be able by adding
having a heading of their space on an
actual water heat work yeah and go back
a few frames if that's possible so we
see some things just elaborate I'm good
yeah notice Ben Franklin right there is
running low morale steak stand which is
actually what if you go to Philadelphia
haven't been or you can actually buy
cheese eggs from the real Ben Franklin I
think so yeah so we got no discipline
yeah you we've got Lance fresh who
worked at bleach report Adam left go who
you might know from inside the NBA
Tuesday nights and then this is a Craig
and Adam right there we did we added
ourselves there as a Sixers fans I'm
also pointing at the screen like you
guys can see so yeah a real Smith Tina
Fey Charlie Day the Frank I'm blanking
on the name Danny DeVito yeah we have we
have we got every other a celeb in there
if you look at the crowd in this shot
you will see that it's just a ton of
funny people that are just like like we
just like copy and paste them everywhere
9 team yeah yeah so they know you got
Meek Mill pops up raising the cat and
you've got em night on the Left employer
render oh no there wasn't this scene I'm
sorry it was the last series the overlay
it's just a matchup of all those
celebrities faces into every other guy
in the crowd absolute nightmare he is
close my lord
excellent thank you Billy was really
split on a TV show this kind of reflects
that this is Anthony out here and that's
from his actual letter yeah yeah you can
read that we translate his rep letter
into medieval and he has tons of
ping-pong balls
six men doesn't have a hot some Easter
eggs there Milton Espada [ __ ] we got
some pumpkin juice and the peasants of
green the truth you all sake Mary Jo al
know that I will James bird watching you
I will always believe in you please
so like this might seem like it's
supposed to be like comedic but this is
like a real heartfelt scene for us you
will be the light that proves this is
exactly my readiness the fruits of the
process was soon ripened a harvest moon
there's like an actual these all day I
cancelled everyone the next row is like
that and no matter what you must always
always trust the process make sure they
hold on Covington we read in part
birthday then read say makies like si
about his beliefs and put into the idea
it's like
stains I cook ever to render they like
Christ or barber and over and over but
we had to do it
beautiful beautiful beautiful
alright yeah they created this is
supposed to end there originally and
then things change the storyline changed
I like the Eskin is the FA's doodle
which is a reference to Howard us in
that slightly grateful I got a
first-round pick for Nolan's
okay fine toppy t protective really
saying breach the castle walls it's
going to be fine father Okafor is
guarding the door
laughs sending home door over 400 so
when the Sixers all bust in here oh I'm
sorry that families all bus on the
Philly family is all just a bunch of us
knew and Yahoo's all Philly fans over
here these made spilled my water ice
Yahoo so come here gotta have the a
galore cake watch me still hold true
yeah a creep awesome so I want to take
some questions
well first let me tell the Sam hinkie
story real quick so oh yeah it quickly
we found out that Sam hinkie when this
episode came out was teaching at
Stanford and his phone was blowing up
and it was all people like Daryl Morey
texting him telling him about this
episode and he was concerned that we
were mean to him but it turns out we
weren't mean to him and I was like drunk
at this party that we went to with all
the analytics people it was at a bar and
Sam hinkie was there and I was like
freaking out I was I was so nervous yeah
I was not as drunk and I was watching
Adam just like drooling over Sam hinkie
and like basically cornering him for
like 20 minutes telling him how much he
loves you
thank you so much I'm like we will never
hurt you you never have to worry we'll
never be mean to you will never hurt you
I promise it was he was like trying so
hard to get out of the conversation and
I still Oh
sorted him away so I blew it and that's
why we make cars oh now we aren't good
in person
yes Sam doesn't return our calls anymore
yeah so alright so let's hands candy man
23 says as sizers fans are you guys
still salty Kauai made that shot
no I'm neither fan yeah yeah but the
scisors are good and what I like about
them is they're like oh they're good at
reading how big you are like they can
immediately know if you're a medium but
no and yes I hate that he made that that
sucked
I hated that game it was an amazing shot
but being on the losing end of one of
those things is it's not fun
so that sucked but Kauai isn't is a
great player someone else asks someone
says Patrick Reed says how do you decide
what trades are bite worthy enough and
that's an interesting question because
it really comes down to like if we it's
there's really no rhyme or reason it's
just like if we think something's funny
or if an idea meshes with something you
know we'll do something about it like
there's no route we did the marShon
Brooks non tricky you know and that's
not those barely story when he at when
they thought they mixed up the trade
with Memphis and Phoenix in Washington
that was like a non-story but we had a
funny idea for it and so we did that so
there's really no metha that's what's
funny
we're rarely worried about being topical
because we never can be that fast with
stuff we're always worried about doing
the most interesting or creative take
and so it's really you know we always
whenever we have a meeting and something
makes us laugh we're like there's
something there for laughing at this
other people will laugh so that's that's
how we decide that Craig any other
questions you answer no I think we
should roll into Episode seven the Feast
of the East Eva and yeah yes if someone
s to the west yes there's someone else
about fester the West and we had
considered during if that's the West but
we never got around
sorry there we see still there so your
employer wins the beginning of the
horses those horse things adventure
here's an honest is by the way like a
demon he's just like guy with big hands
who takes a chicken with this hit pause
it story behind the development of the
scene we wanted to do something though
about how every year it's the same thing
like there's always there's LeBron and
then there's some other team and they
always everyone tried to hype it up but
we know what's gonna happen and it's
amazing how consistent it was also Robin
Lopez King l2 he's got Brook Lopez head
same head we used sheriff Smith with all
his tattoos not moving you're all gonna
look up at me and then there's a new
king in the east
this again didn't we do this last year
we've got chemistry and the defense to
take you down
don't sleep bottom here before that was
the Raptors for the north well soon
yeah basically no king we went down like
the Wikipedia article of like although
we do the finals
there's the Eastern Conference Finals he
puts us into whatever is like wow so I'm
over the Broncos been deep fragrance to
the Wikipedia but I noosed Telugu know
just north about basketball this year
yeah no score per person so like older
because yeah that's a little bit first
boot but he has human legs so I don't
know how it works yeah and we would
reference the old me I was like I'm
Lance Stephenson blue in his face it's
time I mean it so we gave LeBron Jameses
armor from the very first episode
notice the basketball chandelier in the
background yeah our backbone ours
Richard Silvius he loves to hi
basketballs and get everything so you'll
find basketball 7s kg was Kevin Garnett
only apparent from there
nothing is possible and then we this
ending was added because we had to let
things play out and then when they got
Dave's boss or the three woken one or
something like that in the series the
Celtics
we added that you know they swept them I
forget but either way they got they know
let's pop it so take a few more
questions sorry you want to finish were
you saying that oh I was just I was just
saying that uh that we added that ending
to make it like the kind of like a
reference to the red wedding which is a
thing that happens in Game of Thrones so
let's uh let's take some questions great
you have one that's popping out to you
someone says I'm guessing Craig
disguised voice I don't
Kawai voice was a little bit of Adam and
then also we used quite actual voice and
just put some effects on it to make him
sound like a demon or white Walker but
now he's changed and he talks like this
and you can see that now that the soul
box powers been gone he talks like this
yes so everyone's asking what is the
horse that does horse things based on is
based on a horse yeah so someone says
maybe have you guys have you Mac says
have you ever thought about Steven
Naismith on GOC as stay tuned maybe he's
in the final season premiering this
Thursday at noon and let's see how do
you know how do you graduated with
Patrick green how do you decide if you
have an episode with one or two topics
well it was earlier we it was sort of
like an evolution from the first episode
we did which was a ton of little
vignettes to like the episodes now which
are like usually one whole thing but
occasionally we have a bit that's just
kind of short and so we can put two
things in there but it just kind of was
an evolution and and you can see as the
show moved from what it started as and
especially what it's become in this
final season you'll see you'll you can
see how it just kind of slowly evolved
that way although a couple episodes last
season were two parts I think maybe just
one all right so let's move on to the
final
third of the four seasons father of
balls sensual Dornan's music lover nasal
music this is a I love this intro' I
swear my top ten moments you fought me
on this we had a fight about this
because Craig thought I was too modern
I'm like Craig it sounds so good just
use it yeah sexy thank you for winning a
better
I love the drawing foul show that is one
of my favorites it's my favorite place
to draw fouls
why are you tried basically we tried to
write the scene set every single line
was like a clever insult just like old
times I don't have time for your games
Brody some of us are still in the
playoff it's both a sparring of skills
and a sparring of insults most valuable
ankles before your next series also the
setting that they're in is based on the
place where bran trains with Jaime
Lannister and Game of Thrones
you might notice it looks similar so
this is some of our first like real
basketball action so shout out to some
of our animators who who did this this
is crazy
take it from me I know what a crazy
season is I am very familiar of
basketball
James Harden is a guy who I started off
not liking and I've started to like more
and more and in this season I was i
favored James Harden over I just I kind
of liked him more than Russell Westbrook
and so we had Westbrook win but James
Harden a blast laughs trash that's right
you all also didn't the Rockets most no
I guess no stress also mother foil top
three all-time James
that is a reference to when he thinks
that O'Donnell foils your defensive
Donnell sign today yeah or the tree both
dolls the realm MVP now he does what he
wants right if now he does what he wants
now if you excuse me that we went on a
ski buddy Spurs this is our way of being
topical about the playoffs which is that
we created a book dues now that would
kind of tell the story and we were
working on it up until the day the
episode came out was around the finals
mid final six games yeah it's very hard
to be topical and animate stuff but when
we make static pictures like this we're
able to do it very last minute and get
it in their demise when the pumpkin I
really love the artwork in the post
which is again a combination mostly
Richard but we know I gets it out even
like it was just like hi something
really proud of it like it's a ton of
stuff this book if you get a chance you
should um yeah you should pause it and
check out some of the fun stuff yeah I
actually looks like this posit here so
we can just you can just see some of the
detail on these books we have like so
many jokes crammed in there so you got
the flick with the furrier dealer hi REE
yeah as a three years worth is unlike
the three years of so if you go up if
you
forward a little bit you'll see okay so
like yeah you'll see that this book is
the battle between the Warriors and the
Cavs are the three years Worf I just got
a ton of stuff including the the famous
toaster there with it didn't exist but
we spied storybooks you can kind of we
could let it slide yeah it's like a
magical item room but there's we got the
ring chasing there's andre igudala
holding a bird and reference the holding
uh it's the Bulls but others a rooster a
dynasty right here in Los Angeles the
again Lord magic I want to become a
dynasty well the first step is to trade
all the little buggers who send
inappropriate Ravens then we signed
big-time free agents
we called the scene I love the kids
notice the and Jim bus yeah this was a
beautiful marriage of Game of Thrones
and basketball
this was the year Lamar we're getting a
request we're naked the barn time so
yeah we have to apply shout out to our
animator Matt who kind of made and
designed a nakedly bar
that's what a human dragon egg looks
like
yeah so a lot of this stuff with it some
players and being poor a few things born
from eggs
we don't really not really consistent
with that lore but this has got to be my
favorite ending of the thing so we do
have a couple more quick fun things to
show you let's take a couple quick
questions and then we'll show you a
couple things so so one question is okay
Kairi story
Suraiya says why is hard and painting a
sequel that was a duck and the idea is
that he's drawing a foul
like he draws fouls in the game good eye
we actually looked up local water fouls
in like the Houston area and the duck
that is painting like is an actual
species of yeah waterfowl that lives
near Houston and in Texas
yes but blues something I can't let's
see there's one more okay so turbo turbo
Bayes er says I need to know who does
Jason Statham is that me I do Jason
Tatum yes I think you can Tatum no yes
he's named Jason take him yet we'll get
to that later but he's a pretentious
British voice you know we went to do so
okay so Craig you want you to explain
what we're about to see now some special
exclusive stuff sure okay why don't we
start with will show you so these are
two deleted scenes from season four so
you have to keep in mind these would
have come out two years ago in the
context of what was going on in the NBA
then the first scene will show you is
assuming we're gonna do about the
Warriors and we ended up doing
sorry we ended up doing Cady's tour
testing the market but this scene was a
scene where he shows up to Golden State
and he's getting fitted for his rings
and he's getting paid a portrait painted
of him for as my next chapter yeah I
went Kevin I am yeah what joins the
warriors here that was a scene for that
an alternative scene will be quiet
unless you watch could you understate my
height a tad I'd say less 7-foot and
more in the six nine range come now
Kevin it's time for your ring fitting
for my ring but it's not your winter
don't you think it's a bit young in the
season for that but one can never be too
prepared Kevin it's the warrior way the
notes of lemon in the rose oh but it's a
bit harsh on the eyes don't you think
looks like you're about two inches two
and a half surprising girth for a man so
slender well you measured my pinkie did
you normally wear rings on your ring
finger don't be so silly Kevin do you
expect your ring finger to fit all five
rings yes oh so that seam did make a
fire but no but still a chance maybe not
I wanted to point out that I want to
point out that the artwork is really bad
there because I drew it really quickly
these are called what we call thumb
addicts their thumbnail sketches really
quick drawings and they help to block
out the scene before we do the more
intense storyboards and really flesh out
every detail so that the animators have
a clear guideline of what to animate
because animation takes so long to do
you need to do a sketch first you can't
afford to animate something that you're
not actually going to use so that was
kind of an experiment to see how the
scene would look but ultimately we
didn't have gone with that scene and
similarly here is another scene we're
gonna show you about the mavs it was a
different mark human scene I think was
actually gonna originally be one of our
first scenes of the season when the Mads
were struggling a bit and they I think
it was like we planes all things and
they were like yeah we're gonna play the
whole thing so okay yeah yeah we're just
you're quickly
so sorry so basically what this was
after a road trip when the Mavs had like
lost a ton they want no way like won a
14 game losing streak or something like
that and this is a scene of them
arriving home after after that road trip
and but in the first before the half 42
Mark Cuban yeah yeah so let's say let's
go ahead so it's a crossbow that shoots
hot dogs right all tunics or whatever
you like put straight up into the
balcony gets the fans excited even if
we're losing may I try oh sure I just
need something to load into them here
I'll use my whole back oh I don't advise
chainmail you see it's made of metal and
that can cause a lot of harm
okay now I'm pretend to be a fan would
you I'm sorry pretend to be a fan right
and for that reason I'm out he also fell
into a shark then Lord Commander Carlyle
I see well back from a road trip why
your grace and oh it was very nice the
weather on the west coast is splendid
this time of year and how did we do
oh you know well Harrison Barnes quite
the acquisition he's playing like the
leader we'd hoped he'd be so we won some
games then
well um not exactly but oh we won no
games
um never your grace I mean it did go to
overtime in Sacramento we scored
dozens of points each game what is our
record now I believe it's um let's see
three and wait uh no that's our two and
thirteen hmm and where does that put us
what are our chances would you say well
we're currently favored to win the
lottery quite the gesture could you do
with me a favor now
yes hand over there and just pretend to
be a fan I'm sorry
so we go I just want to answer one great
question we got so are s are speak says
when harden and Westbrook are having
their 1v1 and they're talking about the
techniques are using is that meant to be
like The Princess Bride scene or was it
a coincidence and very astute
observation yes it is it was we you know
we're always trying to do these notes we
kind of do these homage --is wherever
they they kind of fit and that was based
on that scene the idea was that in that
scene the Princess Bride you haven't
seen that movie they're like having a
sword fight and these guys are two
experts and like marveling at each
other's moves and we did the same thing
with a basketball moves like oh very
nice a a double sham got into a river a
Euro step like so great observation by
our speak I'm really impressed yeah yeah
so so - Rand R says do you guys believe
your ending will be better than Game of
Thrones garbage that's not very nice
- Rand are it's hard to write endings
for a show I have faith in you
thank you okay I like you but I that
it's up to you I will say about the
ending which you guys can watch it
starts the first episode of our
four-part series finale
the episodes are a little longer for
this one it starts on Thursday and one
thing to note is that we're trying
something a little different it's a it's
a it's like a four-part cohesive story
that we hope ends it in a different and
interesting way but maybe you'll like it
maybe you won't but even if you don't
like it then all that is is just a
parody of Game of Thrones right we're
parroting
the fact that they're ending wasn't as
strong as people would have liked and
someone had asked will there be an
episode longer than 10 minutes all I
will say is wait and see yeah well thank
you guys so much for joining manlings we
really appreciate you guys spending a
little bit of your night with us it's
really meaningful and hope we'll be back
tomorrow doing the next season and then
we'll do it again on Wednesday 5
Thursday it's the premiere yeah forgiven
right see it thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]